he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government and beginning in the
spring of 2020 Dr fouchy began to set
National policy that affected the way
that 330 million Americans lived their
lives for goodness sakes I'm telling you
wear a mask keep social distancing
there's nothing political about that but
who is Anthony fouchy people who have
conspiracy theories those are people
that don't particularly care for me in
this short series we will do what the
establishment media have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in America Dr Anthony fouchy
don't you think it's time that you step
down and let someone else who has a more
effective message actually
[Music]
no